was there a point when you were like I
want to become a thing on the internet
I'll give you the long real answer I
really wanted to be rich and Anonymous
and there's like one video that Caleb
was found of me being like content
and I did that for a really long time
and then what happened was Kylie Jenner
hit the front of Forbes and she was like
20 and a billionaire I was like
depressed for a day you know my ego was
like no it's just Chris and it was
organized and then Conor McGregor came
out with proper 12. boom 600 million and
then Huda Beauty and then the rock
finally I was at a buddy of mine he's
very famous and I was like don't you get
tired of like the weird messages people
threatening your family I was like that
sounds horrible he said if that's the
price I have to pay for the impact I
want to have I'd make that trade every
day of the week it just stabbed me after
that point I was like all right we're
doing it